being you know in the Jiu-Jitsu
Community like I'm around you know as
you are all like incredibly tough people
like physically tough people mentally
tough people but you know I've seen some
of those people taken down yeah by a 120
pound woman you know not not not from a
grappling perspective but they are taken
apart Yeah by a woman in their life and
and vice versa I've seen men you know
who like it really is shocking how much
leverage we give to our romantic
partners and how little discussion we
really genuine discussion we really have
about it how much we really are ever
trained to think about it you know
there's nothing in school that teaches
us about it so much of literature and
art is an idealized version of it
so little of it is is real and no matter
how it evolves even when it ends in
tragedy or uh drama
I feel like what people don't do enough
is appreciate the good times like
appreciate
how beautiful it is to having taken the
risk and two having experienced that
kind of love I think when you look at
people and that are divorcing each other
uh there's a Edgar Allan Poe quote the
years of Love have been forgot in the
hatred of a minute I always kind of am
saddened like deeply saddened
uh people who seem to forget how many
Beautiful Moments have been shared when
some
reason some drama some breakup leads
them to part ways yeah yeah it's
interesting that you came to that not
being a divorce lawyer because I I felt
that way for a long time and I really
try to say to my clients
like in the courtroom at the negotiating
table I have a role to play where I have
to be sort of like a Pit Bull or you
know some kind of a like a courtroom
sociopath but behind closed doors like
I'm very candid with people and try to
be much more emotionally attuned with
them so you're an empath in the sheets
and sociopath in the streets exactly
correct that's well said I get a new
tattoo idea that's good I like that
I I but I I do believe when I'm behind
closed doors with people I say to them
how you end things is going to be how
you're going to remember the whole thing
and and that's unfortunate because you
know you watch like a two-hour movie
and if the last 15 minutes of it sucked
you go well that movie sucked like well
the first hour in 45 was great you know
but you walk out with this bad taste in
your mouth
I I'm genuinely
in awe of how easily people forget that
they loved each other
and and I'm amazed Because by the time I
meet them and by the time they they hire
me to be a weapon against the person
they were in love with
there's nothing but animosity there
and so I have to try to imagine
what these two people looked like when
they were in love with each other and
how that even existed but
I have to tell you like I I you know I I
don't function that way like I
every woman I ever had a relationship
with like I when I think of them I I
don't think of the ending necessarily I
think of I try to think about the
greatest hits I try to think about the
moments that were wonderful where I
loved them and they loved me and like
there was joy and there was connection
and I I don't know why you'd choose not
to you know it's there's that old Axiom
I don't know who said it that
if you don't learn to find joy in the
snow you'll have pers you'll have less
joy in your life and precisely the same
amount of snow
and yeah and I genuinely believe like
okay the relationship ends this is where
it ends we're done now
I I am making a choice as to how I Will
Remember You and and we do it in
relationships like I I always tell
people you know if you ever want to see
a couple light up if they're ever like
the couple at the table that's you know
it seems like they got in a fight or
something ask them how they met
and most people when they talk about how
they met like the the face softens they
both in the other person looking at them
telling the story gets that look you
were talking about before and because
they remember that thing and how they
felt at that moment and when when this
person was a choice
not a default not their automatic plus
one but the person they asked to the
wedding not though of course you're
bringing her it's your wife you bring
your wife places like it was
still hey there's like you know three
and a half billion women and I'm picking
you you know like that that feeling and
and I don't know when why when a
relationship ends
you can't do that a lesson I learned
when my mother passed away of a very she
had a two-year terrible battle with
cancer and was on hospice and was very
very sick
and it was a very slow and awful end
and I remember one of my worst fears was
that this is how I would remember my
mother for the rest of my life that I
would never be able to think of her that
I didn't think of what she had become in
the last months where she was withered
away to nothing in this bed you know
and I learned over time that memory is
very kind that like that faded somehow
and that now like when I remember her I
remember her healthy and vibrant I
remember her laughter I remember
positive things some of that is I like
to look at photos of that or but some of
it is just how I think memory works and
I I don't know why we don't apply that
to relationships and I think part of it
is because we have this binary view of
relationships that it's either success
which means you live happily ever after
for the rest of your lives and die
together
or like in short succession
or it was wrong it was awful and I I
don't understand why that would have to
be how we do it I think we could look at
relationships like what they are which
is Chapters
in a book
and that book is our life and those
chapters all have significance and none
of them would have the later chapters
none of them would happen without the
prior ones so there's this beauty of me
of that and it's I don't know if that
it's a choice
or if that is how it is
and the rest is just narrative that
we've put on top of it culturally for
some reason well I think to push back a
little bit I think memory
can also I think it is a deliberate
choice because I think memory can
basically that's how trauma works it can
Surface the negative stuff and the
negative stuff completely drowns out all
the positives so it's I think
uh it's a deliberate choice to make your
memory probably work that way you know
in relationships betrayal can do that
right sort of uh cheating infidelity
like one event can almost erase the
entirety of your
uh understanding of the past and all the
memories are sort of shrouded in this
darkness of okay this what I believed
was true is totally untrue and started
to overcome that and still appreciate
the Beautiful Moments I'm
continually astounded
by how
long
the hurt and anger of betrayal can
reverberate
I I have clients who were four years
five years passed when the divorce ended
the cheating was discovered and there is
angry as they were the day they found
out
and and I I don't know what that's about
oh yeah because I also have clients that
they like look back on it and they go
you know
we screwed up like we were you know we
didn't do the best but we did the best
we could do at the time and you know we
like there should be stars for Wars like
ours you know there should be champagne
for the Survivor yeah that's beautiful
like we made it through you know like we
survived it and we were fools and we
were fools for love and there were worse
things in the world to be fools for but
I I also do think that most
relationships where there was infidelity
and it's not a it's not a popular thing
to say and I'll get i'll get pilloried
for it but great you know
I just don't
know and I don't want to blame the
victim of infidelity
but was the relationship really where it
needed to be like had were you truly the
most just dutiful spouse who was seeing
this person's needs be met again we've
established in the granola story that
people can sometimes with good
intentions not be meeting their
partner's needs or perceiving their
partner's needs or their partner isn't
communicating them the right way or all
of the above
but I I I've rarely seen very happy
content couples that cheat on each other
and so I I understand there's a shame in
saying this person cheated on me or I
cheated on this person
because I represent you know I represent
I represent the cheater and I represent
the cheated I represent the victim of
domestic violence I represent the
perpetrator of domestic violence I
represent the person with the substance
use disorder the person married to the
person so I I don't get to choose the
white or the black hat like I have my
client and that's my client
and and it forces me to put myself into
their story from their point of view
and I think that kind of radical empathy
that you need to engage in on a daily
basis to represent people in those kinds
of proceedings
it just I don't know it's it it just
doesn't seem like there's good guys and
bad guys you know it just seems like
it's complicated
and people's intentions and where they
actually end up are different yeah I
think there's some sense in
uh still remembering the Betrayal as
it being a symptom of taking life a
little too seriously too seriously where
you don't
uh life shouldn't be taken that
seriously you should be able to laugh at
it all I like the story you say you know
be able to appreciate the battle that
should give stars for those kind of wars
that we fought and just kind of be able
to laugh at it all so especially with
love like it's just so absurd yeah like
it's so it's just crazy it's so crazy I
mean like I don't I you know I I think
it's funny I think
this is real Candor but you know as a
man like there's nothing funnier than
when you finish masturbating you know
there's no more humbling moment and I
like to think about the fact that like
the richest famous most powerful person
in the world they jerk off
you know the most powerful man in the
world jerks off I'm sure you know all of
them do I mean you probably know them so
you could ask but in that moment where
you just you come and you go
what am I doing like what the now I
gotta wipe that like oh good lord and
there's this feeling of but a second ago
this seemed like a great idea and it was
by the way it was a great idea but but
you there's this moment this Satori you
know where you just go oh like what this
is so silly well like that's love that
sex like it's crazy like when you read
other people's infidelity
the text messages the emails because I
have to do that all the time and I'll
tell you how we make the sausage
in a divorce lawyer's office this some
of the most entertaining moments is
dramatic readings allowed of people's
infidelity exchanges but their lovers
the sexts yeah the sects and the the
like you know like it's just so
ridiculous because people have to go
through like all kinds of gymnastics to
be able to meet and have sex in weird
places and you know
and you're reading this and you're
reading these texts and you gotta go
like oh my God and by the way like I've
represented some very powerful people
and you read their texts with their
lover or even their spouse like even
their spouse you know
and they're just pathetic I mean they're
just like so not powerful they're so
like hey babe you know I I have a I have
a remain totally nameless I have a very
powerful wealthy famous former client
where there's a whole series of texts
about is my dick weird
which by the way I think the answer is
if you have to ask if you have a weird
dick the answer is probably yes because
I've I've owned one and I've never
thought is this weird
but but I I
the fact that you're having this
discussion like it's absurd it's
hilarious like love is hilarious it's
bizarre it's such a weird vulnerability
it's such a a basic visceral human need
you know it it really is something that
we just
you know it's mysterious it it it but it
but it doesn't have to be that
complicated I don't think that even
betrayal like I said it doesn't have to
be that complicated I think we can frame
it differently yeah you can laugh at the
whole thing I mean I I think what we
don't often do with ourselves
is uh look back at text or look back at
emails or look back at Google search I
did that recently just looking at what I
searched for like 10 years ago 15 it's
like forget last week just look at your
Google searches
last week and you're like wait a minute
what why did you just search for this
right 50 times right like why did The
Karate Kid three pop in yeah exactly why
and like you're like where is Ralph
Macchio now where who is he dating yeah
uh wise and then mother and then yeah
and then you're like a restaurant nearby
yeah like how did I go from this to that
but but it made sense at the time so so
when you ask someone
how did our relationship Fall Apart
it's like looking at the Google search
history of yourself from tenure you
don't even know why you were thinking
about those things and now you want to
understand why you did what you did felt
what you felt she felt what she felt she
did what she did and why the two of you
how you impacted each other and
interacted with each really you think
that's doable
but you've so you've in in the courtroom
does that come up like text messages
that resulted in uh with whoever you're
cheating with yeah I mean you know
cheating doesn't come up as much because
most states are no fault States now so
why someone's getting divorced whether
it's infidelity or you know it doesn't
matter there's no good spouse bonus or
bad spouse penalty well there isn't I
mean you know I'm wearing that like
that's well you can have we've had times
where we have to prove infidelity
because we want to prove what's called
wasteful dissipation and marital assets
which means that you were spending money
that was marital money on a Paramore
That's What the legal name for a ex you
know for a boyfriend or girlfriend in
the marriage and usually the person
calls it you know that or that
piece of but we call them Paramore
yeah the Paramore yeah and the the the
you know sometimes we have to prove
inclination and opportunity we have to
prove that this person had the
inclination to cheat and that they had
the opportunity to cheat and then we
want to show that okay so when they went
away that should be considered
dissipation and marital assets so if you
go out to dinner with your brother you
didn't dissipate the marital estate but
if you bought your power more a Tiffany
bracelet that would be a dissipation
marital assets and the person's entitled
to a credit back for that from what was
taken out of the marital estate so we do
sometimes have to authenticate text
messages on the witness stand or in
depositions you know and what's
interesting about that is the way people
approach it like people sometimes try to
pretend oh no this is just my good
friend you know and which is just like
you kill your credibility you know if
you oh no she's just my very good friend
she's not she's not that makes no sense
whatsoever for or no we were just
friends at that point and then several
months later is when we once this
marriage was over that's when we got
together as partner right that's
ridiculous
but sometimes people just own it
just own it like I did a deposition of
an executive once and
you know posing counsel I thought they
were going to really hit him they were
like and looking at this credit card
receipt what was this charge for for
this hotel he was like oh that was for a
hotel room that I got with uh with my
girlfriend
and you were married yes yes what did
you where did you stay at the hotel it
was we didn't even stay we actually just
did like an afternoon delight rolled
around in bed for the day
yeah and it was like well now you know
took all the Thunder out of that what's
the downside of doing that that seems
like there wasn't it actually I think
helped his credibility it was my client
so I thought it was the right move we
hadn't really discussed it in advance
but he he was naturally intelligent
enough to go yeah my credibility like
I'm not gonna lie under oath I'll admit
what it was but I'll do it in such an
you know we did it like at the end like
Eminem at the end of eight mile like it
was very like yeah I cheated on her with
this person now tell these people
something they don't know about me you
know and and that's kind of how I try to
as a trial lawyer we we actually in my
firm refer to it as the Eight Mile
strategy which is like we will if I know
there was a text message sent you know
you piece of I hope you die my
client sent that text message to his
co-parent
I I on my examination of my client I
will say I'd like to have this marked
for identification shown to the witness
what is that it's a text message
who's it to
a plaintiff
you sent it yeah read it out loud for
the court
oh do I have to
I think you should
uh you're a piece of uh s does it say s
no what does it say well it's a
profanity so you say it
uh you piece of I hope that you die
yeah you sent that to her yes why
I was really mad do you think that was
good
no do you think it's helpful your
co-parenting relationship with her
no why did you send it then
you know she sent me like 50 texts
exactly like that and I never responded
and I pushed it down every time and then
finally I just blew up at her if you had
it to do over again would you do it
differently you know I wish I could say
I would but the truth is I'm human and I
was at my limits and I'm watching
opposing counsel cross out entire sheets
of their cross-examination because it's
gone now they thought that they had
their like Perry Mason moment they had
their like did you order the code red
moments and it's gone now because if you
just own and accept your fault or your
issues in the relationship
you can take a lot of the power out of
that
and I wish we wouldn't take text
seriously
I don't think we should have substantive
discussions via text I think text was
designed for are you here yes 15 minutes
away or I got here safely love you like
that substantive discussions are people
love having arguments via text and I
have to say when you read other people's
text messages as I am often forced to do
yeah it is amazing
because just like that Google history
you were talking about
I don't know how the hell you got from
one thing to another like I was just
reading on actually on on the way here
in the car I was reading through a text
exchange between two co-parents in the
middle of a custody thing that I'm I'm
involved in
and
it's
you never cared about anything and I'm
gonna you have no right to take the kids
and then the next day nothing in between
the next day
Maddie got a uh you know a good great
honor science thing oh that's great
she's doing so well it makes me so happy
yeah her teacher said she's doing really
well yeah that's really great to see
I'll be there about 15 minutes late no
problem see you then
wait like it was a day ago was there
some I want to know was there a phone
conversation in between where one of you
went hey man listen I'm really sorry
about that oh no look we were both
pissed whatever or is it just like you
did that and then we're supposed to
pretend that didn't happen and now we're
just going to talk about what Maddie got
on her test yeah well sometimes a good
nap or a good night's sleep can solve a
lot of emotional issues totally get it
but is there some if if you're looking
just at the texts like it begs the
question
wouldn't you take the nap and then go
Hey listen I just woke up from the nap
it turns out I was really tired like
does that not happen by text oh no
that's uh because sometimes it's hard to
probably apologize for being an
right so I think we use just text we
humans use
all kinds of forms of communication to
kind of vent I think it's the wrong
thing to do but
people do do that text has a permanence
though it's writing I mean it's writing
you should think like a lawyer I like
anything like a lawyer but lawyers think
lawyers think like detail you know and
and why would you write that down
like you know writing it down like would
you write it down and would you put it
on a billboard in Times Square because
like that's ex everything you say on
Facebook or Instagram Canon will be used
against you in a court of law like every
photo you post I mean that's going on
with uh what's his name Jake Paul or
whatever Paul and Dylan danis right now
that guy's girlfriend every picture has
ever been put on the internet of her by
her is being weaponized right now to
reference an earlier part of our
discussion that's love you take a big
risks big risk putting it out there yeah
um putting out there on text putting out
there on social media what is the reward
of doing it via text worthwhile I'm
listen the reward of love I think is
worth the risks of love but the benefit
of communicating by text does it Merit
that that risk of that being in writing
that the person can reflect on and
review and scroll back and get heated up
again about I don't know we just take
risks and we're vulnerable with each
other there may be something about text
that for whatever reasons inspires a
kind of candor
because I think it it is a new way to
communicate right in the scheme of
things and so sometimes you know we
don't know the thing until it's really
come into existence so I don't know I
think it started as something that we
just communicated in a very
extemporaneous unplanned way like texts
were meant to be I'm here I'm outside
whatever it might be
and so what happens when you
start to talk about more emotional
deeper bigger things or visceral things
or more emphatic passionate things using
a technology that was originally just
being used for the other purpose I don't
I don't know the answer that what I do
know is yeah as a lawyer
a from an evidentiary perspective
and B I just know what it looks like on
the outside like I I I know when I read
it what it looks like and that's that's
not always accurate like to just see the
it's like when you watch you know a
video of someone at just their worst
moment you know and the person that
tries to say but wait that's not me like
that was just me in that moment that was
me at this incredible low point and
I I think as a lawyer my job is to
weaponize that and to try to say okay
this this low point is indicative of who
they actually are yeah and when I'm
defending someone I'm supposed to say
you know well this is their low Point
we've all been to a low point and this
is just a moment in this person and to
judge them by that moment would you want
to be judged by your worst moment so I
have to be able to look at that both
directions
yeah I mean I don't think anyone looks
great on text I mean there's so much of
our communication that that is missing
your you know your your expression like
my sense of humor does not do well via
text like I I because I have like
sometimes a sarcastic sense of humor or
I have a dry sense of humor and it does
not always translate well to text the
Nuance of things is lost sometimes you
know yeah but that's what makes the risk
of it uh hilarious I mean the Emojis the
memes all that
um taking a risk the dry the there's a
risk with the text if you do some like
dark dry
statement right that's a joke and then
the pause and then there's no response
for a couple hours I mean that's
beautiful I don't know that's a that's
like a it's this you know it's it's the
gap between the two trapezes you know
like once you've hit send and you're
like well let's see where this goes like
this is coming back now you know and and
you're waiting and waiting it's like
that moment of just hang is yeah that's
a rush I mean that's a rush that's a
beautiful thing we'll have uh my friend
Michael malice living close by and if if
uh the courtroom or ever to see the text
between us I would we would be both in
jail for many many years